you look awesome it's nothing but love
between Demi Lovato and Wilmer
Valderrama the NCIS star surprised his
fans with a live stream on Instagram
over the weekend then his axe made jaws
drop when she joined him on the stream
okay so here's what I love about these
two they still chat like they're besties
I don't know about you but I'm super in
my feelings right now so let's see more
shall we I hope you have an amazing time
do you give me when you get back when
you get back oh okay cool well I'm done
with work on Wednesday so how that's a
boy okay so if you weren't catching
those friendly X vibes get ready to be
smacked in the face with it just listen
to how sweet they are with each other
when they say goodbye see you angel I
love you I cannot it's too sweet now if
you don't know Demi and Wilmers history
let me fill you in the two dated off and
on for six years between 2010 and 2016 I
knew I loved him when I met him Demi
opened up about her relationship with
Wilmer noir 2017 YouTube documentary
I've never loved anybody like I loved
Walmer and like I still loved Wilmer
seeing all this footage of you guys I
was like I kind of want them at the end
was that like still a possibility can we
hang on to that for like a few more
years you never know what's gonna happen
and I don't know it's gonna happen
Wilmer was also by demi side following
her apparent overdose in 2018 at the
time a source told ET that the actor was
spending quote hours with Demi and her
family at the hospital as she recovered
adding he visits Demi every day he can a
second source told et he was quote
shattered when he heard the news of her
apparent overdose even after they broke
up they continued to be very good
friends
they have mutual admiration for each
other and he has and will always believe
in her he's watched her fall and has
seen her rise Wilmer opened up to ET
about their strong bond in 2016 you know
we've been we've been you know best
friends for about six years you know he
we haven't necessarily been dating for
six years but we have six years of
friendship and it's been it's been has
been beautiful all I did was was love
her exactly when she needed me to love
her and you know and we just we stay
honest that's it a year later Demi
shared this pic with her ex on Instagram
writing best of friends no matter what a
month later he helped Demi celebrate her
25th birthday at Dave & Buster's in New
York City and in 2018 Wilmer raved about
his exes performance at the March for
our lives event in Washington DC she's a
hero man she's a retired too young to
young men and women out there I think
that she's she's you know she's
literally the image of a recovery and in
getting their life together something
tells me these two could still end up
together and I am rooting for it of
course we'll keep you up to date on all
things Demi sir make sure to keep it
locked on et until next time I'm Holly
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]